there it is man
um first of all for people who don't
know you originally before you linked
with drumwork and Conway you were kind
of working you were like the sneaker guy
so you were working out of a sneaker
store in Buffalo yeah yeah so were you
kind of like ever known to be a rapper
at that same time or are you kind of
like everyone's sneaker plug like kind
of breaking up no I was uh you know I
was working like you know I was the
manager at the sneaker spot for a long
time so you were the plug yeah kind of
not really not really because I wasn't
on no back door [__] you couldn't set
some shoes aside for someone I could if
you if I really [__] with you yeah you
know what I'm saying but outside of that
I wasn't really doing that type of [__]
I was just really working there to try
and support my dream right you know what
I mean and uh you know people definitely
knew that I was you know I was rapping
back then too because I was doing like
ciphers and uh they're at the store
actually I was doing that I was doing
shows all around the town I was doing
shows out of town so you know it was
just something that I was doing in the
time so that I could you know just
support the dream and just support
myself so what ended up kind of being
um the bridge from you doing that to to
sign in with uh drum work it was really
like the pandemic like once the pandemic
came around I got furloughed from work
because you know nobody was going to the
sneaker store to go buy no kicks and
[__] so right you know uh we ended up
you know all getting furloughed there at
the store and um you know I was just
locking in and you know when the
opportunity came back to go back to the
store and work
um the company I was working for they
just what company was it um if you ever
heard of DTLR Villa oh yeah DTLR yeah I
was working with DTLR and they they just
you know it was just a few situations
that happened there in the store
um where I just wasn't comfortable
working in the store and I ended up
leaving and uh you know two days later
that's when Conway reached out to me you
know what I mean like I kind of just
took a big leap of faith and just
trusted God and you know I didn't know
where I was going to go next or what was
going to happen next but you know it
just didn't feel right I wasn't I felt
like I wasn't being treated like a human
being at the end of the day that I had
value well I feel like to the last
couple years you've kind of gone through
like some real like artist development
like I feel like you've been putting out
music but you've also been kind of able
to sit to the side and and watch you
know go to these big roselda shows or go
do South like last year you did South by
Southwest
um I think
I don't I forget why Conway couldn't
make it but I remember there was a show
that last year I saw you do with a stove
God but like it was dope to see like
kind of like I feel like every time I
see you you're kind of like getting the
like standing on your own a little bit
more because I feel like it's hard to
come in when you're coming in with
somebody like Conway because everyone's
going to kind of associate you guys
together
um but I feel like you've done a good
job of kind of being your own man you
know what I mean that's that's like one
of the biggest things for me is is crazy
that you even bring that up because
everything that I've done to this point
has been to support that right you know
what I mean because like you said it is
kind of hard like you know it's hard to
have two stars really shine bright
together but I know like you know I know
I'm a star too so you know I got to do a
good job of making that known and just
you know anytime that I do have a chance
to kind of you know do a show separate
like separately or you know just do my
own thing you know I mean I always take
those opportunities like Conway that's
my big brother you know what I'm saying
like shout out to the big bro you know
what I'm saying but you know I gotta
shine too you know what I'm saying and
that's what I'm gonna do